bonjour Nicolas duup merci beaucoup
d'être notre invité politique ce matin
vous êtes député de lesson président de
Debout la France on va évidemment
commencer en parlant du conflit entre
Israël et le Hamas et la France qui a
voté la résolution de l'ONU qui demande
une trêve humanitaire immédiate ce que
demande clairement Emmanuel Macron il a
redit vendredi à Bruxelles vous le
soutenez mais je demande de la même
façon une trêve humanitaire c'est
impératif j'ai condamné avec la plus
grande force l'attaque terroriste du 7
octobre mais je considère que ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui à Gaza euh est une
abomination et loin de servir Israël sa
sécurité risque d'entraîner un
engrenage absolument dramatique pour
Israël pour sa sécurité son existence
même et pour la paix la paix du monde
donc Israël a le droit et le devoir de
se défendre face à cette organisation
terroriste d'éradiquer le Hamas mais ce
n'est pas une punition collective sans
aêidere humanitaire qui va régler le
problème c'est pas vrai
donc vraiment on est à une enfin chaque
mot compte et et et et je pense que les
responsables politiques français d'où
qu'ils viennent devrai vraiment mesurer
chaque propos parce que nous sommes sur
un fil mais vous le dites chaque mot
compte est-ce qu'Emmanuel Macron a eu
les bons mots pour Emmanuel Macron a
fait une tournée catastrophique pour bah
parce que il a eu des discours
différents selon les interlocuteurs sa
diplomatie est en état de mors cérébrale
comme dit ce matin Nicolas bavrez dans
dans le
Figaro article c'est pas moi excellent
excellent parce que Emmanuel Macron est
arrivé en Israël en sortant sa coalition
contre le Hamas qui était quasiment un
engagement de la France à à rentrer dans
la guerre qui était une aberration et
dont Israël ne voulait pas après l' a
dit il a dit on en verra pas de
militaire non mais attendez une
coalition c'était absurde même l'Élysée
a éé obligé de démentir ce qui prouve
l'état
d'amoturisme d'Emmanuel Macron c'est
l'amateurisme cette idée de coalition
mais ça n'a aucun sens c'est absurde
d'abord à sa place j'aurais été plutôt
en Israël j'aurais pas attendu temps
ensuite j'aurais surtout pas sorti cette
idée de coalition antihamas qui n'a
aucun sens et dont Israël ne veut pas et
puis ensuite il est allé faire le tour à
disant à chacun quelque chose différ
tout ça est dérisoire et c'est triste
parce que ça abîme la position de la
France mais tout le monde sait que la
France n'a plus de politique étrangère
indépendante tout le monde sait que
Emmanuel Macron ne pèse rien en matière
de politique étrangère parce qu'il s'est
décrédibilisé comme en sur le territoire
national comme en France auprès de tous
ces interlocuteurs et pourtant il est le
seul à l'heure actuelle à être aller
parler à tout le monde il est allé en
Israël il est allé en S Jordanie en
Jordanie en Égypte pourquoi vous dites
qu'il estisé dit Nicolas bavrez dans ce
son éditorial vous pouvez parler à tout
le monde et dire n'importe quoi ça fera
pas avancer les choses quelle est la
politique étrangère de la France mais
pourquoi il a dit n'importe quoi mais
parce que on ne peut pas d'un côté dire
on fait une coalition antiamas et après
aller voir les autres en disant on va
voter la résolution de l'ONU il a un
moment il faut savoir où on habite et ma
position en tout cas la mienne est
claire c'est une position j'allais dire
goienne et je je suis triste d'ailleurs
que dans la vie politique française
cette position n'a été exprimée que par
Dominique de Villepin Hubert Vedrine
hier dans là aussi dans un autre article
pour moi condamnation totale de l'acte
terroriste abominable du Hamas
euh éradication du Hamas oui punition
collective euh qui risque euh de créer
un engrenage fatal pour Israël dans les
années à venir non et c'est là où il
faut une trêve humanitaire une pause
humanitaire pour permettre d'abord
concrètement parce que faut être concret
d'acheminer l'aide ce qui se passe à
Gaza hier ce matin est dramatique donc
il faut acheminer de l'aide ensuite il
faut aussi une perspective politique euh
beaucoup d'Israéliens le disent aussi
donc c'est n pas une position mais mais
quelle est la différence entre ce que
vous nous dites ce matin et ce que dit
Emmanuel c'est que je ne propose pas une
coalition antihamas absurde illuso sur
Le Rest vous dites exactement chi reste
oui mais il faut une crédibilité pour
dire quelque chose chè madame il faut
pas raconter tout est le contraire de
tout ces intercuteurs ce qu'il a fait
dans la dans la tournée je crois que là
maintenant il faut pas se soumettre à
l'Union EUR lui aussi dire qu'il
fallaitouvrir le processus de P sou une
se chose s rattraperé enfin c'est en
votant la résolution de l'ONU et en
abandonnant sa position européenne
d'ailleurs cette résolution de l'ONU
monde qu'il ne peut pas y avoir de
politique étrangère européenne vous avez
vu les votes ils sont très différents
selon les États mais tout ça est très
confus moi je pense qu'il faut être très
clair là il y a urgence urg
à une trêve pour acheminer les secours
et éviter encore une fois c'est
important je crois de
pousser le peuple palestinien dans les
bras du Hamas parce que ce qui est
terrible dans ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui c'est ce qui est terrible et
ce que disent certains Israéliens c'est
qu'il est bien sûr légitime et on
comprend les Israéliens presque arrivés
de de taper fort mais taper fort à juste
titre et notamment les circuits de
financement du Hamas ils sont où les dir
g du Hamas ils sont où comment on
reconstitue une Autorité
palestinienne qui peut dialoguer et qui
reconnaissent Israël voyez c'est des
choses tellement revenir mais juste sur
la trêve sur la trêve vous dites vous
êtes d'accord avec Emmanuel Macron vous
souhaitez une trêve c'est pas ce qu'on
dit hier Éric Zemour et Marine Le Pen
Marine Le Pen elle a dit pas de trêve
tant que les otages ne sont pas libérés
mais c'est je suis désolé je ne suis pas
d'accord sur cette position je pense
qu'il faut une trêve je pense que la
politique politicienne s'arrête au
moment où il y a des enjeux pour le pays
je ne sais pas je pas ça ce que je veux
dire c'est que la France c'est la France
elle a une responsabilité historique
parce que
justement les états reçoivent la France
après il faut que la France a un
discours clair et je crois
fondamentalement que en tout cas moi je
demande une trêve ça ne veut pas dire
d'être faible contre le Hamas pas du
tout au contraire pour être fort contre
le Hamas il faut ne pas punir les ne pas
les pousser dans les bras du Hamas c'est
tellement élémentaire parce que ce qu'on
joue là c'est pas seulement la vengeance
du 7 octobre c'est la préparation de la
suite est-ce qu'on veut un siècle de
drame ou est-ce qu'on veut au contraire
quand même préserver un petit chemin de
paix qui est très difficile est encore
possible pour vous mais il sera toujours
possible parce qu'à un moment ça
s'arrêtera mais dans quelles conditions
voilà l'enjeu ce qui est TER aujourd'hui
quel est l'enjeu c'est de trouver des
interlocuteurs de paix de chaque côté
voilà et qui sont les interlocutes ils
viendront naturellement un jour puisque
peut pas y avoir un suicide collectif
tout le monde ne peut pas se ce suicide
collectif dans la région ne pe pas pour
vous la solution à deux états c'estêt
une perspective à plus long terme c'est
pas une pers auour auourhui la solution
à deux états elle paraît une chimère
mais comme le disait très bien Isaac
Rabine mais cet homme malheureusement
assassiné par un extrémistes comme
d'autres ont été assassinés du côté
arabe euh il le disait quand je lutte
contre les terrorismes je ne pense pas
au processus de paix mais euh quand je
pense au processus de paix quand je fais
le processus de paix je ne pense pas au
terrorisme la phrase est un peu
différente mais qu'importe c'est le sens
c'est ça qui est important parce que
sinon sinon on allume une mèche qui va
se propager dans tout le monde arabe
c'est ça l'enjeu et c'est ça vretud
aujourd'hui quand vous quand vous que je
suis ce que je voudrais qu'on qu'on dise
bien parce que je lis bien j'ai bien vu
les réactions j'ai publié une vidéo
immédiatement d'ailleurs tout s'enflamme
d'ailleurs c'est bon signe ça veut dire
que si on est critiqué des deux côtés
c'est qu'on a raison je crois que en
tout cas la France c'est pas n'importe
quel pays c'est un pays qui a une
tradition qui a une influence mais qui
doit avoir un discours cohérent clair et
qui ne change pas selon les
interlocuteurs et selon les moments vous
parlez du rôle d'autres pays quand vous
entendez Erdogan qui qualifie le masse
de mouvement de libérateurs et qui
accuse l'Occident d'être le principal
coupable des massacres à Gaza qu'est-ce
que vous vous dites ah ben moi j'ai
toujours été clair sur Erdogan et j'ai
toujours dit notamment en France j'étais
le premier à dire qu'il fallait refuser
les constructions de mosquée financé par
Erdogan donc s'il y en a un qui a
toujours été clair là-dessus d'ailleurs
le grand paradoxe et je crois qu'il y a
peu d'explication c'est que ceux qui
hurl le plus contre le Hamas quand ils
ont gouverné je parle quand ils ont
gouverné ont été le plus faible
vis-à-vis des mouvements islamiques
sur notre sol et c'est paradoxal je pas
rentrer ceux qui ont gouverné de gauche
comme de droite ceux qu' ont toujours
gouverné et ce que je dis pensez à qui
répblain tous ceux qui on gouverné
depuis 20 ans aujourd'hui ils ont un
discours légitime de soutien à Israël
légitime parce que moi je soutiens
Israël face à cette abomination mais le
vrai soutien à Israël c'est pas de
mentir à Israël et je pense que
paradoxalement une grande faiblesse
vis-à-vis de toutes ces mosquées qui ont
été intégristes j'allais dire ou radical
ouabit ou salafistes ou Frères musulmans
qui ont été construit en France et donc
moi je pense qu'il faut à la fois être
très ferme ce que ne fait pas Emmanuel
Macron encore une fois et son
gouvernement sur ce qui se passe en
France et avoir une
position ferme et juste au Moyen-Orient
et ce n'est qu'à cette condition qu'on
arrivera à éteindre l'incendie là-bas et
aussi chez nous ce qui se passe en
France justement ce sont 719 événements
ou incidents antisémites depuis le le 7
octobre est-ce que pour vous
l'importation du conflit est là mais
bien sûr qu'elle est là puisqu'on a
laissé s'implanter dans notre
pays des des mosquées des un
islam très radical alors que on aurait
dû
favoriser les pareil les Français
musulmans qui respectent les lois de la
République qui ne veulent pas imposer la
charia et qu'on a laissé tout faire et
donc on paye une immigration massive on
paye une absence
de rigueur face une absence
d'organisation du culte musulman en
France heureusement sont pas tous pro
Hamas donc il faut mesurer là aussi ses
paroles il y a des millions de Français
musulmans qui ne sont pas soutiens du
Hamas et je ne veux pas qu'on rentre
dans une fausse guerre de civilisation
il y a des éléments dangereux qu'il faut
sortir de France mais il ne faut pas non
plus là
aussi faut faire attention à ce qu'on
dit et je vois beaucoup de paroles de de
de comment dire je je je je m'inquiète
vraiment des paroles trop trop
systématiques qui laisserait croire des
choses fausses et et donc le rôle de
l'État c'est à la fois d'être très ferme
et de d'éviter l'installation sur notre
sol de gens dangereux qui soutiennent le
hamass mais il faut traiter la cause
j'ai vu qu'on interdisait les
manifestation la manifestation c'est le
thermomètre moi je veux qu'on traite la
cause mais c'est une bonne chose d'intir
c manifestation ah pour vous il faut pas
les interdire je vais vous dire il faut
interdire s'il y a trouble à l'or
publicque bien sûr mais qu'à justifieré
le concept ça pour interdire celle de
samedi je pense que c'est maladroit je
vais vous dire pourquoi parce queon
casse le thermomètre mais on s'attaque
pas à la cause de la fièvre mal il
faudra mieux expulser ceux qui sont
dangereux il faudrait mieux s'attaquer
aux Frères musulmans qui prent une
idéologie de haine plus et qui
soutiennent le Hamas plutôt que
d'interdire la surface et là aussi de
victimiser ceux qui vont dire bah voyez
on a pas le droit de soutenir la
Palestine je crois que dans cette
affaire il faut absolument tendre la
main au modéré à ceux qui reconnaissent
Israël qui veulent la paix qui veulent
simplement un État palestinien et être
inflexible et beaucoup plus ferme ce que
veut faire mais ce que veut faire Gérald
d'Anin avec son projet de loi
immigration est-ce que vous le voez mais
est-ce que vous le voterz mais mais ce
projet de loi est mais mais c'est une
arnaque pourquoi c'est une arnaque mais
parce qu'il y a rien dedans ce sont des
des mesurettes il y a pas rien il y a
des mesures pour faciliter l'exculion
justement j'ai posé sont des mesurêes
absolument pas à la hauteur de l'enjeu
on ne contrôle pas nos frontières il
faut contrôler nos frontières nationales
il y a pas d'issue haut que cela il faut
examiner les demandes d'asile en centre
fermé à nos frontières il y a rien
là-dessus il faut supprimer l'aide et
les visas aux pays qui refusent de
reprendre nos
OQTF c'est il faut rétablir la primauté
du droit national pour éviter
l'application des jurisprudences
européennes et des directives
européennes ces quatre points F il faut
pas ramener les djihadistes de Syrie les
femmes djihadistes il y en a 80 en
prison donc si vous voulez ce qui est
terrible dans ce qu'on voit c'est que
rien n'est fait pour vraiment maîtriser
l'immigration en France c'est pas vrai
le ah ben ce texte mais ce texte est une
si je votais ce texte je mentirai aux
Français je ferais croire aux Français
que le gouvernement fait quelque chose
alors il y a quelques mesurettes qui
peuvent être intéressantes mais qui vont
rien changer sur le fond je vous ai dit
les quatre points C points comis on va
revenir parce que Marine Le Pen hier
elle a dit qu'elle pourrait elle voter
ce texte si l'article 3 n'y figure plus
vous c'est pas votre ronnement je ne
voterai pas un texte quoi qu'il dedans
même si l'article quel je voterai
peut-être quelques dispositions pour pas
compliquer la vie des services de l'État
mais il faut pas mentir au français ce
projet de loi immigration ne traite pas
le problème migratoire français et si on
veut traiter le problème migratoire
français il faut faire les CIN points
que je vous ai dit c'est sur mon site
internet de Debout la France il y a tout
dessus alors là-dessus vous êtes
d'accord avec les républicains qui eux x
aussi demande un référendum sur
l'immigration et qui eux aussi veulent
que il a une primauté du droit national
sur le droit européen est-ce que là du
coup vous vereez juste première question
est-ce que vous voterez leur révision
constitutionnelle ce sera le 7 décembre
à l'Assemblée donc vous VO je vais vous
dire chère Madame j'ai commencé ma
carrière politique mais vous m'avez pas
répondu répondre j'ai commencé ma
carrière politique tous les républicains
votaient le traité d'Amsterdam qui a
communautarisé la politique migratoire
cétait en 1998 je venais d'être élu
député je me suis fâché avec jacirac et
Philippe sin pourtant mon ami euh parce
que j'ai dit on ne peut pas transférer à
Bruxelles la politique migratoire on va
avoir un chaos c'était il y a 25 ans
alors moi je me réjouis que les
républicains découvrent que tout ce
qu'ils ont signé au niveau européen
était une catastrophe je l'ai dit à
chaque traité et j'ai eu un parcours
politique mouvementé parce que j'ai osé
dire la vérité donc moi je me réjouis il
faut qu'il soit à 3 % ou à 5 % pour
comprendre que j'avais raison quelle
tristesse quelle gâchie si on avait dès
le début une position de fermer on n'en
serait pas là donc bien évidemment que
moi je voterai toutes les initiatives
qui vont au cœur des problèmes mais je
crois que les Français n'en peuvent plus
euh de la politique de la communication
des faux semblants
euh ça sert à rien d'aller des leçons au
Moyen-Orient et de laisser la France
tomber aux mains des islamistes c'est ça
la réalité donc occupez-nous de chez
nous et là-bas soutenons Israël quand il
lutte contre le terrorisme et soutenons
les Palestiniens quand qui sont
bombardés donc vous voterez le texte on
a compris et Olivier marlex pour le
référendum puisqu'il faut bien poser une
question il propose souhaitez-vous
approuver une modification de la
Constitution pour que la France
réaffirme sa pleine souveraineté en
matière d'immigration très bien j'en
suis ravi et je dis à Olivier marlex il
va falloir continuer parce que sur le il
faut vraiment se retirer de
l'organisation de Schengen parce que son
attention le référendum ne suffira pas
si on ne rétablit pas nos frontières
nationales parce que euh il faut
contrôler nos frontières et ça je
voudrais que les Français comprennent
que c'est rien de montrer son passeport
pour aller à Madrid à alon pas à lond
Londre c'est déjà fait à Madrid à en
Allemagne c'est rien puisque quand on
prend un avion on enlève sa ceinture et
ses chaussures donc ça coûterait rien ça
serait 2 minutes dans les aéroports pour
montrer son passeport et il faut être
cohérent et c'est là où les républicain
ont fait un pas je m'en réjouis mais il
faut faire l'autre pas faut rétablir les
frontières nationales et vous signerez
leur petit nationale puis la la même sur
le depuis des années est-ce que vous
espérez qu'il dépose une motion de
censure les républicains mais je je le
réclame pas qu'il la dépose qu'il la
vote déjà ou qu'ils en dépos une ça
m'est complètement égal on est dans une
situation quand même
extravagante on est la on a eu le 14e
493 c'est moi qui pour les non inscrits
fait le discours à chaque
fois les républicains passent leur vie à
critiquer le gouvernement et estime que
Emmanuel Macron on nous précipite vers
dans la dans le fossé et à chaque fois
ce qui sauve le gouvernement qui le
sauve les députés républicains donc moi
je dis au républicains libre à vous
faites ce que vous voulez mais n'ayez
pas un décalage entre votre discours si
vraiment vous estimez qu'Emmanuel Macron
fait du mal à la France et son
gouvernement bah votez la censure nous
aurons une dissolution probablement et
ce sera tant mieux parce que là cet
après-midi va encore y avoir deux
nouvelles motions de censure qui ont
très peu de chance de passer puisque les
républicains refusent de faire de faire
tomber le gouvernement sur le budget
est-ce que du coup oui mais est-ce que
du coup les oppositions se
décrédibilisent pas à enchaîner les
motions de censure qui ne passe pas est
il faut être clair vis-à-vis des
Français il faut être clair vis-à-vis
des Français c'est un dénis de
démocratie sans
précédent si vous reprenez les écritures
de Michel Debray dans la préparation de
la Constitution le 493 était un
mécanisme exceptionnel pour dompter une
majorité ou faire clarifier les votes
d'une majorité pas pour faire passer des
lois de finances des lois de sécurité
sociale sans aucun débat attention
Michel rard mettait souvent le 493 dans
une période à la fin des débats mais là
c'est pire que tout madame borne monte à
la tribune comme vous allez voter compte
il y aura pas de débat en 10493 fini
mais si ça se passait en r Tex a été
rejeté en commission que les de premers
articles excusez-moi en com mais
attendez le travail on est au Sénat
là le travail dans l'hémicycle et le et
le sol qui compte commission c'est un
travail préparatoire donc vous n'allez
pas voter mon budget donc je vous
interdis d'en débattre mais ça serait en
Russie ou en Chine qu'est-ce qu'on
dirait c'est intolérable et donc moi je
suis clair je vote les motion de censure
parce que je dis qu'on peut pas rester
encore 3 ans et demi dans un pays
ingouvernable il y a deux légitimités
qui s'affrontent la légitimité que je
respecte du président de la République
il a été élu qui nomme un gouvernement
qui n'a pas de majorité et où les
Français quand même 6 semaines après
l'élection du président n'ont pas voulu
lui donner une majorité pour appliquer
son programme et ce qui va pas c'est que
Madame borne au lieu d'essayer de
trouver des compromis dans des débats
parce que c'est justement le le boulot
du du débat dans l'hémicycle avec les
amendements trouver des compromis et
bien au lieu de cela elle arrive et elle
dit circuler il y a rien à voir ça ne
peut pas durer et moi je vous mets en
garde si les débats n'ont pas lieu dans
les hémicycles à l'Assemblée nationale
et au Sénat ils auront lieu dans la rue
et ça c'est très grave donc on joue pas
avec nos institutions comme ça là il y a
un jeu malsin de Madame born et je ne
vois pas comment les républicains
pourront rester longtemps sans prendre
leur responsabilité alors je souhaite
qu'ils la prenne sur le sujet qu'ils
volulent parce que je ne pense pas
qu'ils pourront rester ou alors cela
veut dire qu'ils aborderont 2027 en
ayant été dans la
majorité
macroniste en ayant constitué la
majorité puis qu'il y a pas de majorité
macronist Emmanuel Macron hier a annoncé
qu'il déposera cette semaine mène au
Conseil d'État un projet de loi
constitutionnel pour inscrire l'IVG dans
la Constitution vous le voterez ou pas
je n'avais pas participé au vote exprès
euh je suis favorable à l'IVG personne
ne le remet en cause dans la CL
politique je ne sais pas si c'est la
version du Sénat qui a été retenu par
celle de l'Assemblée liberté
personn à titre personnel je suis
favorable bien sûr sauf que j'estime que
c'est pas une disposition dans la
Constitution parce que si on utilise la
Constitution pour faire de la politique
il y a plus de constitution à ce
moment-là on met des politiques dans la
Constitution c'est une pure démagogie
alors que personne remet en cause ni VG
et sur le plan constitutionnel euh c'est
une absurdité maintenant si ça fait
partie du piège d'Emmanuel Macron au
moment où le monde brûle flambe au
moment où la situation économique est
désastreuse au moment où il est
incapable d'assurer le respect de nos
frontières de lutter contre S mais c'est
une manœvre de communation c'est pas
juste un engagement qu'il a pris et qu'
tient c'est une manœuvre de
communication diversion dérisoire et
pathétique voilà j'estime que c'est pas
juste aussi le respect pour le coup
puisque vous appelez au respect du
Parlement il y a eu un vote à
l'assemblée il y a eu un vote au Sénat
est-ce que c'est pas le respect rraite
qui respecte le Parlement sur tous les
sujets ce sujet-là est important mais il
est respecté et personne ne remet en
cause donc je le voterai je verrai mais
en tout cas je ne voterai pas contre je
voterai pas contre je m'abtiendrai
peut-être parce que je suis quelqu'un de
sérieux et j'estime qu'on ne joue pas
avec une constitution quand on est
président de la République le président
de la République est le garant de la
Constitution alors je sais que c'est pas
populaire de dire ça mais j'estime qu'il
y a un moment et je le vois en ce moment
peut-être parce que j'ai un peu plus
d'expérience mais je trouve que il y a
beaucoup c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que le
personnel politique n'est plus très
respecté ni estimé des Français c'est
parce qu'il se Liv à tellement
d'acrobatiese politicienne pour plaire
plaire à tout prix que bah les Français
ne les considèrent plus et moi j'essae
je veux en tout cas j'estime que je dois
dire ce que je pense un mot sur les
européennes est-ce que vous serez tête
de liste Nicolas du je ne sais pas
encore on verra bientôt vous attendez
quoi j'attends peut-être que quelqu'un
d'autre le soit parce que je suis déjà
député et il y a des talents quelqu'un
d'autre chez vous non pas
obligatoirement chez moi je j'ai d'abord
défini un projet clair parce que là
aussi la politique c'est quand même du
projet nous avons publié c'est sur notre
site internet 10 mesures pour rendre à
la France son indépendance et revenir à
une Europe des nations gauliennes des
États libres qui coopèent entre eux le
projet est limpide clair maintenant
j'estime étant député national que ce
doit être quelqu'un d'autre qui mène la
liste et quelqu'un d'autre pas forcément
de chez vous j'espère de chez moi ou
peut-être avec d'autrre avec un accord
peut peêre j'estime on verra c'est le
parti quien décidera j'estime que avoir
une Nice Philippo une Nice telino une
Nice Bardella une Nice Marion maréchal
UNECE républicain uneice debout la
France pour les républicains vous les
mettez non mais ça dépend ils aont vous
avez raison je les mets mais bon c'est
limite allez hors républicain ça fait
déjà C ou si listes j'estime que
l'électorat patriote souverainiste
gaulien
Gauliste serait un peu en colère et donc
je dis à tous ceux qui s'écharpe en ce
moment est-ce qu'on peut pas parler du
fond mais est-ce que vous en avez parlé
à Marion maréchal et à jordin je vous
diraai le moment venu mais c'est quand
mais on a un peu de temps ok est-ce que
vous
Croz excusez-moi est-ce que vous croyez
qu'en ce moment où le panier de la
ménagère où les Français ne peuvent plus
vivre pour beaucoup d'entre eux euh avec
le le chauffage qui va commencer à être
payé est-ce que vous croyez au moment où
il y a l'affaire dramatique de cette
attaque terroriste en Israël est-ce que
vous croyez que c'est le moment de
raconter nos salades vous reviendrez
nous en parler merci Nicolas dupignan
merci beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité
on passe au club des territoires